[Music]
the Cape of Good Hope is no place for
swimmers for the currents that surround
it are unpredictable and cruel and the
water is my numbing the cold but there
is one man who thinks this is the
perfect place to Train you got the two
oceans meeting heavy Atlantic over there
Indian over there something down there
your three oceans meeting here
the storm here
in the water it is extremely unfriendly
endurance athlete Lewis Pugh is building
up his body and testing his nerve with
nothing but a costume cap and goggles to
protect him is the shark shield on just
double-check it please you wants to do
something that's never been done before
he's going to risk his life off Eiland
southern shore with the most dangerous
swim of his career we are completely
redefining the eros of swimming
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is a very very best place which I
can change because it's so damn rough
the water swirling underneath you it's
it's scary and courage is a little bit
like a muscle you need to be swimming in
these conditions this is the best
training Louis has come to the wild
waters of southern Africa to prepare for
a very special swim from Land's End to
Dover for five hours a day in 50 days
I think the cumulative effect of day
after day of today in the cold water the
English Channel will make this without a
shadow of a doubt the toughest swim I've
ever done and I just don't know how I'll
do it what can you see Thanks of animals
playing underneath me lots of jellyfish
I haven't seen any sharks yet
let's hear shot birth quicker than you
can imagine Lewis Pugh is a swimming
pioneer as some in the Arctic or some in
icy waters of Antarctica I've swum in
every ocean in the world
the Pacific the Indian the Atlantic
Ocean a sudden ocean of some in some of
the most dangerous waters on on this
earth and the coldest waters I ranked
this 10 out of 10 for food difficulty I
think this is the most difficult to swim
I've ever undertaken by a long way and
he's become a master campaigner fighting
for the future of the Seas I have seen
our oceans change and we need to wake-up
call we need to really take our oceans
seriously and we need to be protecting
them and Lee what I've been seeing is
the impacts of climate change
overfishing and
I've seen how these swims can actually
change things with the long swim he's
campaigning to fully protect 30% of our
oceans by 2030 I've been swimming in you
know in the remote parts the world and
trying to take the message then from the
remote parts of the world into the great
big capitals now I'm going to be
swimming you know along the south coast
and taking that message taking it home
so about a thousand eight hundred people
have swum across the English Channel
so from Dover to Calais or from Calais
to Dover what I'm planning to do is to
swim the full length of the English
Channel so starting in Lands End and
swimming all the way along the coasts of
South of England all the way to the end
to Dover it's five hundred and sixty
kilometers and I think it's going to
take me round about fifty days to
complete it's a it's a mammoth swim so
covering 216 English channels back to
back
luis seeks advice from an old friend
whose ship
the polar explorer hms protector is
moored off Cape Town Matt surrett is the
youngest captain in the Royal Navy he is
also the former hydrographer or chief
map maker and he can help to navigate
the hazards I mean we we grew up
together in Plymouth as young boys he
knows that coastline that like the back
of the hand what I'm looking for is the
places along the coast where we need to
be really really careful cautious just I
mean you've been sailing along this
coast to your whole life yeah absolutely
I grew up in Plymouth and have been in
the Navy for 28 years
the idea of swimming 560 kilometers
which is 16 English channels for me I
can't even I can't even think that
before because it is so much and yes
it's easy to sort of break it down and
say I'm just gonna swim day by day by
day but the furthest I have ever swum
would only get me somewhere too too
close to Weymouth that's 21 days of
swimming
this is paradox I know I will get to the
White Cliffs of Dover I just don't know
how you're gonna swim there hopefully
together they note the dangers on
England's treacherous southern coast so
if you if you look in here often Albans
ledge you can see the rough weather
water indicated the over Falls are
indicated in there but these symbols are
whirlpools they're back Eddie's these
are the most dangerous in my view at
this time of year captain Cyrus was
mindful of the psychological challenge
as well as the physical test you're
inside the silence and there's a sense
of euphoria as you go through here a lot
of people middle of summer lots of
schools on holiday I'm sure you'll see
your maximum levels of support because
people can get close to you but once you
pass they'll see bill the coastline
changes and you've still got an awful
long way to Dover in your finish line
not only am I tired but the team would
also be tired every single day coming
out to see ya and don't underestimate it
I mean it could be that the Solent is
your easiest phase and then you get past
Elsie bill and you'll get that feeling
of loneliness again where you and
our team are on your own just grinding
us out to the end to meet your goal I'm
swimming with a purpose my purpose is
that by the end it's not so much that
I've become the first person to assume
the full length of the English Channel
but what I want is proper marine
protected areas not only around the
United Kingdom but around all the other
nations of the world but the scientists
are telling us is that we need to have
at least 30% of our oceans properly
protected fully protected by 2030 for
our oceans too
to have any chance of survival our
waters around the United Kingdom are
750,000 square kilometres 750,000 square
kilometres and in that you will not
believe how many are fully protected
marine protected areas seven seven
square kilometres out of 750,000 square
kilometres are fully protected no
fishing no oil and gas no drilling no
gunnery practice just leave it alone and
allow nature to recover and to restore
itself Lewis Pugh did his first
long-distance swim on the frigid 5-mile
stretch separating cape town from robben
island and he still comes here to Train
I feel very nostalgic because I don't
need too much beforehand
and coming out here to swim from Robben
Island to to Gator
I was really nervous and it also just
the starter because I just didn't
realize that this would then become my
passion my love and my work you know
campaigning for protecting these
beautiful wilderness areas
the notorious apartheid era prison built
on the island has been preserved and
this remote spot is also home to a
number of endangered species
okay come look over here this has no
entry beyond this point African penguin
colony this Beach is used as a launching
point for long-distance swims and Pew
has seen a change to things that are so
striking the first is just everywhere
you go now everywhere plastic plastic
plastic
plastic everywhere plastic but the
second thing is
this used to be penguin colony
let's just I can't see any penguins and
there's none normally you'd have lots of
them sort of hiding in the bushes here
but
there's nothing here there's nothing I
think I heard one
we did find an academic researcher
conducting a penguin census on the beach
hi how you I'm gonna spear and she too
was struggling to find subjects for her
study have you seen any change in the
numbers of penguins on this beach yeah
I've been here I've been doing this
project for 10 years now since 2008 yeah
and I've definitely noticed a change
there were many more birds in this new
specific route that we do yeah I'm sandy
beach and and then the island is home
howdy how do you feel when you when you
see the numbers just slowly dropping and
dropping and dropping very very sad yeah
do you think they've got a long-term
prospect no it's very difficult to say I
really hope so but it's not looking good
at the moment
I'm angry because I've I feel like I'm
almost being literally and
metaphorically a voice in the wilderness
I've been swimming out in the oceans the
day after day after day and I come
ashore and I tell people about it and
I'm just not seeing a response from
governments and business and civil
society the role of ocean advocate is a
solitary profession but his exploits in
the water do generate attention I've
never ever done an easy Robin either
I don't know that always throws
something at you this waters cold
significantly colder than English
Channel
it's a tough sore leg is absolutely
great training to swim the length of
English Channel so I'm doing this as
many times as possible now today
building up the mental fortitude
physical courage to do this
[Music]
pew heads east through a great stand of
kelp and out into the waters of Table
Bay powered by his rhythmic and
unfaltering stroke these three-hour
crossings are part of the routine he
does these swims every day that the
length of England's southern shore is
348 miles and the conditions will not be
this forgiving
you're on the brink of one emergency
services in garden a thought of the
juice was too dangerous the cold water
reduce consciousness is doctor
[Music]
this is what our ocean should be like
teaming with wildlife seals of dolphins
and whales but I don't see a lot of this
around the world and what I do it's
absolute joy
Lewis Pugh's vision of the future looks
a lot like this
a rocky outcrop of the South African
coast crammed with Cape fur seals
they've been protected from hunting
since 1990 and scientists say their
numbers are on the rise is just
absolutely logical it is what I
absolutely love Kathy oceans are teeming
with seals this is what our seasonal
envy like and should be like if we just
protect them I'm going to dive in here
[Music]
you need to have courage to be able to
do these type of swims you've got to
push yourself into that uncomfortable
situation day of the day of the day
that's why I swim you know around the
Cape of Good Hope or off Seal Island
here because it is extremely
uncomfortable and it's it's a
frightening place to swim I'm in their
environment I'm in their home and they
are wild animals so there's always that
little bit of angst but on the other
hand joy I've seen these animals and the
agility of them and the way they they
swing in and surge underneath you and
then come a look at you
they're two big beautiful doey eyes and
the whiskers and the teeth they're
absolutely beautiful they got a good
layer of insulation they're perfectly
adapted to this place humans are not
meant to be swimming in these waters
well we're not designed to be swimming
in these waters
if he's going to survive the frigid
waters of the English Channel he'll have
to prepare for the cold like the seals
do and fatten up they want to have a a
decent layer of fat so I'm going to go
in there about 100 kgs and then over the
five hundred and sixty kilometres over
the what we think will be fifty days I'm
going to get thinner and thinner and
thinner and it's almost it's a race
against time
are you hungry Lewis mmm my hungry am i
hungry
what's Lewis like if he doesn't get his
breakfast black goes like a hungry polar
bear
I start getting hungry and I just need
to eat more and more and more Lewis Pugh
has spent thousands of hours in the
ocean training for his ultra swimming
marathon but he's also got to spend some
time here at the kitchen counter two
pieces of toast some Marmite four eggs a
big cup of coffee to wake me up
some yogurt and some berries and and
just eat it up a junior swim I'll be
burning so many calories swimming five
six hours a day in big wins with the
waves and also the cold it's just not
possible it's eat it or how many
calories do you take in a day a normal
adult male will be around about 2,500
per day I reckon during the swim will be
close on 10,000 yeah he's looking a bit
lean I would like to see some more fat
on him professor Tim Noakes is an
eminent sport scientist who has studied
Lewis Pugh's physiology on a number of
extreme cold water swims the more fat
you have the the in a sense it's like
you're swimming in warmer water so
instead of being 14 degrees if you're
really fat it's equivalent swimming in
18 or 19 degrees water and once you get
the temperature up to 19 or 20 then you
can you can swim for many hours so Lewis
would I will be advising him to put on
more weight to get much fatter when he
gets cold he starts to corkscrew through
the water because he can't extend his
arms and so that's the sort of thing you
look for you look for how frequently is
he's striking the distance he's
traveling with each stroke and once that
starts to shorten then you know that
you're in trouble and then he will
become he's not fully conscious and
that's what you have to read and the
problem then is that disappearing from
the syndrome that suddenly if you don't
watch us do a swimmer every second and
you go and make a cup of tea you come
back and this nice aroma they lose
consciousness that quickly and they just
disappear and that's happening in this
channel cardiologists also
tanning is Lois pews longtime swimming
partner and a member of his support team
the biggest and most important safety
device should he start getting colored
are the people on the boat and they've
been trained and they know what to look
out for and he knows that the room in
open water swimming is that if the crew
say you're getting out you get out if I
am there I feel he's gotta get out and I
tell him to I know you'll get out if not
I'll take him out
good lord it's blowing 50 2 knots now
it's reeling to go back to bed now but
you need to train in the tough
conditions if you're not prepared to
guard in the tough conditions when it
really does get tough and sometimes june
swims the conditions change and it
starts out a nice day and ends up really
tough if you're not prepared to go out
on days like this I mean I will never
get to Dover it's as simple I've just
received a whatsapp message from the
city of Cape Town says going around
everybody and it reads as follows the
city of Cape Town has released a warning
ahead of hurricane type storm wind
speeds are between a hundred and a
hundred and forty kilometers per hour
stay safe and remain indoors let's go
swimming
I've called off I've caught up a few
swims it's too dangerous
but I I think today today's border line
will see one of my safety caucus is
coming along now and he's very very
experienced on these type of issues and
he's been out kayaking this morning
downwind with the wind so I just want to
get his view on it
a good training session this when this
is swinging with so you just need to
understand you're on the brink of what
emergency services can guard and this
different is if you know Chapa learning
gas yeah in Essaouira much they've
really not say that's a key and so
you're on that edge do you think it's
doable yes or not it is doable
now for a small selection of people and
I can't choose one of those
[Music]
[Music]
after more than two hours in the water
he emerges looking battered and blue
stream is really extreme it's wild
but you know like keep on saying courage
is a courage is a muscle and unless you
train it you won't have it when you need
it and that was wild out there and it's
absolutely fantastic training for when I
get into the channel it'll be great
courage or something George you need to
change it you need to try it every
single day you were working on it yeah
the last couple of hours yep and it's
coming even coming into this little Bay
here with the world of the world of
difficulty yep
so we did it had an S in the back
yes he is you he's got the right biology
and he's trained himself but he's much
more important he's got that is a heart
to do something important and that's
what will get him through this room it's
it doesn't become physiology in the end
it's it's what's in your head and what's
driving you
there's only one way to swim from lands
into Dover and that's putting your head
down and taking a stroke and then taking
another stroke and another stroke and
the way I do this is just simply
counting so I put my head down and then
I take a stroke one and I breathe two
and breathe three and breathe I'm just
gonna keep on going for the next hour
I'm gonna keep on going the next two
hours and three hours the next day the
next week and the next month
until I finally will see the White
Cliffs of Dover
[Music]